>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Carla Hayden: Well
good afternoon.
I am Carla Hayden, the Librarian of
Congress, and I hope you are having
as great a time [applause] at
the 17 National Book Festival.
I must tell you, we
have had quite a day.
And this is going to be
another special session.
I am delighted to be here at
the History and Biography Stage.
I have to admit that I
am a pretty history geek.
And personally this is
means so much to me.
First, I want to sing and I am
not a singer, but I vowed to sing
for Helene Cooper as a reporter.
She joined the New
York Times in 2004
as an assistant editorial
page editor.
And she has been a diplomatic
correspondent for the Times,
as well as a White
House correspondent.
And she is now the Pentagon
reporter for the paper.
And in 2015 she was part of the
team that won the Pulitzer Prize
for international reporting,
specifically for her work
in Liberia during the
Ebola epidemic.
And that same year she received
the prestigious George Polk Award
and the Overseas Press Club Award.
And prior to joining the
Times, she spent 12 years
with the Wall Street Journal, where
she was an assistant bureau chief
of the Journal's Washington Bureau.
And I know that many of
you are fans, like I am,
of seeing her on Sunday mornings
giving insightful, thoughtful words
for us all to think about.
Now long before her life
working high profile jobs
in the country's top papers, she
experienced firsthand what it means
to be swept up in the larger
forces that make front page news.
Her bestselling memoir,
the House at Sugar Beach,
In Search of a Lost African
Childhood, published [applause],
published in 2008, poignantly
describes a world upended.
The book begins with Cooper's
happy, secure upbringing as part
of quote what passed for the
landed gentry upper class
of Africa's first independent
country.
The overthrow of the Liberian
Government in the 1980,
brought chaos, violence and
tragedy to her own family,
who were forced to flee to America.
And with unsparing pros,
she recounts this past
and her ultimate return to
Liberia more than two decades
after a near death
experience in Iraq.
Her newest book, Madame President,
The Extraordinary Journey
of Ellen Johnson Sirleaf,
extends her work to biography.
Sirleaf, who survived Liberia's
political and social upheaval,
became the leader of
its women's movement
and was the first democratically
elected female President
in African history.
And in 2011.
You can give a hand for that.
I see. Yeah.
[Applause].
And in 2011 she received
the Nobel Peace Prize.
We are all thankful that
Ms. Cooper has returned
to her birth place
to write this book.
And her book is impressive for
both its detail and insight
in providing something
that we can all look to.
Ms. Sirleaf is reserved
in her personal life
and her presidency is
examined in this book.
We are all thankful that Ms. Cooper
is extending her writing career
to biography and history
and we look so forward
to having her talk
and be with us today.
Now, at the close of her
talk, you will have a chance
to ask her questions at
one of the microphones
that you see setup on the isles.
And you should know that
this is being live streamed
and you are on camera.
And you will be archived at the
Library of Congress [laughter].
So, make these questions good.
So, please join me in giving a
warm welcome to Ms. Helene Cooper.
[ Applause ]
>> Helene Cooper: Hello.
Thank you so much, Carla,
for that great introduction.
This morning, I woke
up to the sound of rain
and I thought nobody
is going to come.
So, I am really happy to see that
all of you managed to make it today.
You clearly are, like
myself, book lovers.
For me, this book began
12 years ago while I was
on a reporting trip
in Eastern Congo.
I did not know it at the time.
We never realize in a moment when
significant things are happening.
At least I do not.
I have been on assignment for the
New York Times in Eastern Congo
as part of a series of
stories that I was writing
about development in Africa.
I went to Ghana, to
Ethiopia, to Kenya.
And I remember that with
each place I kept thinking
that despite the poverty and
challenges, none of them seemed
as bad off as my own home country
of Liberia, which had just come
out of two decades of civil war.
Until that is, I got
to Bukavu in the Congo.
Oh finally, now I am
home, I thought,
as I crawled out of the
small single engine plane.
After the semi desert of
Ethiopia in the Savannas of Kenya,
Bukavu was otherworldly lush, just
like my home country of Liberia.
Leafy green mountains,
luxuriate banana trees.
The same beautiful verdant
landscape that we have in Liberia.
And the same sense of
abandonment that comes
from having a population ravaged
by years of pointless wars.
Hundreds of boys trolled the
streets with nowhere to go.
Downtown buildings were marked with
holes from rockets and grenades.
The only cars were the
white U.N. SUV vans.
What struck me most though
in Bukavu were the women.
As I drove into the city, I passed
women I had known all my life.
There were old women
with huge bundles
of bamboo sticks on their backs.
There were market women in their
colorful dresses huddled at the side
of the road selling
oranges, eggs, nuts.
There were young girls
sitting in front
of village huts bathing
their little brothers
and sisters in rubber buckets.
No electricity was anywhere around.
But one 10-year-old girl had dragged
a bucket of dirty creek water
up the hill to her house so she
could wash her four-year-old sister.
These were the women that I
had grown up with in Liberia.
The women all across Africa --
the worst place there
is to be a woman --
who somehow manage to carry that
entire continent on their backs.
I remember one woman in particular,
who stood out to me in Bukavu.
It was twilight when I passed her.
And she was trudging up the hill
with all these logs
on her shoulders.
Her husband was walking
just in front of her.
He carried nothing.
Nothing on his back.
Nothing in his hands.
Nothing. He kept turning around
and telling her to hurry up.
That image has stayed
with me for 12 years.
A few months after
my trip to Bukavu,
I was back in the United States.
When the women of Liberia,
my home country staged an incredible
power play, defying centuries
of history in the most
patriarchal of places --
they flooded to the poles
and staged a democratic coup.
They upended years of male rule
and voted for Ellen Johnson Sirleaf
to be President of Liberia.
The first woman to be democratically
elected President in Africa.
I knew instantly that I
wanted to write about this.
This book looks at
the what happened.
It is a book about Ellen
Johnson Sirleaf and what it took
to upend all those years
of male rule in Liberia.
But it is also a book
about what drove the women
who put her in power.
And it is a book that looks at how
they did it, who these women got
so fed up with being exploited
and raped and assaulted
that they decided the only way
forward was to turn the tables
on the men anyway that they could.
In 1985 a young Ellen Johnson
Sirleaf was thrown into jail
by Samuel Doe, who was then
the President of Liberia.
She was put in a cell next to
men who were condemned to die.
She listened in that
cell as the men next door
to her were executed
by a firing squad.
Afterwards, she sat in the
corner of her [inaudible] cell.
Her eyes squeezed shut.
Her lips moving silently
as she prayed,
wondering if the soldiers would
rape her before they killed her.
Hours passed.
Outside the soldiers drank
and became even rowdier.
Then, just past midnight, one
soldier walked up to her cell.
Stood at the bars and stared at her.
Several minutes passed in silence.
Then he said, I am
going to fuck you.
He opened the cell door
and Ellen rose to her feet.
Her heart pounding.
But just as the soldier
was entering her cell,
a voice behind him
said, as you were.
The soldier dropped his hands.
Retreat said the voice.
The soldier closed the cell
door, locked it and moved away.
Her savoir stepped
forward into the light.
He was slightly older than
the others, in his mid 20's,
with beautiful dark
skin and a serious face.
Looking at him, Ellen wanted to cry.
They say you [foreign
language], he asked her.
[Foreign language] she replied.
Say something in Gola.
[Foreign language], she said.
Her rescuer stared at her
for what felt like forever.
Finally, he said, okay I will stay
here tonight, nobody will harm you.
So on that night, Ellen
Johnson Sirleaf was not raped.
But someone else was.
A young Geo girl who also
had been captured and brought
to Shefland [assumed spelling]
was gang raped by soldiers there
in the early hours of the morning.
As Ellen huddled in her cell.
Whether Ellen's would be rapist took
part as well, she would never know.
After brutalizing the girl,
the soldiers brought her naked
and crying hysterically into
Ellen's cell and pushed her in.
she looked to be around 19 or 20.
She was bleeding and her
eyes were wild with fear.
Jumping up, Ellen put
her arms around her
and lowered her onto the floor.
In the corner, the two rocked back
and forth clutching each other.
Slowly the girl's cry softened.
Her naked body started to tremble.
Leaving her new cellmate for a
moment, Ellen went up to the bars.
There were a few soldiers milling
around alongside the
one who had rescued her.
[Foreign language], Ellen said.
Her voice shaking.
The soldiers looked at her.
She tried again.
Think about your sisters.
Still nothing.
I beg you.
At least bring [inaudible]
something for the child to wear.
Finally, one of the men laughed
and brought back a piece of cloth.
And Ellen helped the
girl cover herself.
For the rest of the night,
the two huddled side by side.
They did not sleep.
Just sat and rocked back and
forth as the minutes ticked away
until dawn when the
soldiers came for Ellen.
As she walked to the jeep, Ellen
looked at her young Geo cellmate.
The two women had spent
less than 12 hours together.
One was now going to face the
man she was certain would be
her executioner.
The other was staying with the men
who were certain to rape her again.
The jeep pulled away and
Ellen turned in the seat
to stare back at the young girl.
She would never see her again.
But in many ways, that young
Geo girl would change the course
of history in West Africa.
The Geo girl would become
another stick, a fuel in the fire
of the women's movement in Liberia.
Little girls do not come
out of the womb vowing
to become activists
for female power.
They do not spend their
childhood thinking
about how they will repair
their dignities large
and small that bleed women daily.
It is a series of things that
multiply and turn ordinary women
into movements of female
determination.
You are living your
life sweeping floors
at a Reninbaum [assumed spelling]
drug store in Madison Wisconsin
when your husband storms
in to yell at you
in front of your white boss lady.
You are stunned by the violent shock
of a hand slapping your face
delivered by the man who promised
to love, honor and cherish
you until death do you part.
You feel the warm, wet skin
of a brutalized naked hysterical
young woman as she crouches
in the corner bleeding after being
savaged by the men who sworn an oath
to protect Liberia and her people.
I wanted to be a school teacher
like my mother, Ellen said,
looking back 30 years later.
Describing that night at the
Shefland [assumed spelling] Barracks
to me, she would use the
mental sleight of hand
that is common amongst
survivors of unimaginable horror.
She would relive the events of that
night with no emotion whatsoever.
The joy ride on the beach, which
the soldier told her would be her
execution site.
The useless pleas from
the condemned men
that she found a way
to help them be spared.
The overwhelming terror of men
who know they are about to die.
The overwhelming terror of
knowing you are about to be raped.
The gut clutching anger of holding a
young woman after she has been raped
by soldier after soldier
after soldier after soldier.
That is what I wanted to do
when I was young, Ellen said.
To teach. But the young
Ellen, the [inaudible],
may have started off wanting to
teach, but this was not a woman
who is destined for the [inaudible].
Hers would be a different destiny.
One launched in a jeep by the young
Geo girl who had been her cellmate.
President Doe did not realize it,
but in locking Ellen Johnson Sirleaf
up in jail, he created both
an international cause celeb
and ignited the women's
movement in Liberia.
All across Liberia young women
were riveted by the story
of this jailed female political
dissident, who was standing
up to the men running the country.
Eventually, after a year and
under pressure from women's groups
in the international
community, Doe released Ellen.
But he had created a monster.
The stage was now set
for the revolution
that will overturn gender
politics in West Africa.
But the men still had one more
act to play and it was a doozy.
I could stand up here
for hours going
on about what Charles
Taylor did to Liberia.
But that needs to be the
subject of his own book.
The tribal war he started.
The child soldiers.
The hundreds of thousands
of people killed.
The wars he launched in Sierra
Leone and in the Ivory Coast.
He kidnapped children from
their terrified mothers.
His forces went on a
raping and killing spree
that spared almost no one.
Once again, as they had
so many times before,
it was the Liberian women that
carried the country through.
While the men were waging war,
the women in Liberia
all became market women.
Traveling by foot to the border
to get food to bring back
to a starving population.
They had the babies of their
rapists in the forests.
Strapped those babies on
their backs and went back
into their market stalls
or sat on the side
of the road selling oranges.
And they bided their time.
When the war finally ended,
they made their power play.
In 2005, 12 years before pantsuit
nation became a secret Facebook
group, and I am with her buttons and
bumper stickers sprouted on lapels
and SUV's here in America, the
women of Liberia held a master class
in how to get a female
elected president.
[ Applause ]
They had a perfect vehicle for
their guerrilla campaign --
Ellen Johnson Sirleaf.
A woman who was supremely qualified,
who by far out qualified
the men who were running.
But who also had no
qualms whatsoever
about playing dirty politics
and fighting any dirt the men
would fling with smellier dirt.
The election came down to a choice
between the 67-year-old Harvard
educated global bureaucrat
and the professional
football player George Weah.
George Weah was a world
renowned football player.
He was a start in Europe
where he was a striker
for the Italian team A.C. Milan.
In 1995 Weah won the Ballon d'Or.
He was named FIFA World
Player of the Year
and African Player of the Century.
Two goals in particular stood up.
One was against Bayern in 1994
when he embarrassed not one or two,
but three Bayern defenders with his
quick pivots before letting rip a
gorgeous sally into the near post.
The other goal known around the
world as the goal was in 1996
when Weah destroyed
the Verona midfield
as he single handedly slalomed
his way down the pitch, twitching,
turning, bucking and weaving
all the way to the Verona goal
in a legendary performance
that Liberians
who watched it using their
makeshift tiger batteries
because there was no electricity,
still talked about
it a decade later.
That Weah had no college education
did not bother his youthful
supporters, who countered that
the Verona goal showed its
own education.
At the other end of the spectrum
was Ellen Johnson Sirleaf.
Finance minister under
former President Tolbert,
dissident under former President
Doe, United Nations, World Bank,
IMF, Pedigree, Allied,
turned fool of Taylor.
She had morphed from an abused
wife, cowering and hunched
in the front seat of her
husband's car while he beat her
to an international bureaucrat
and iconic political dissident,
who was attempting to do something
no woman had ever done before.
Win by popular vote the right
to lead an African country.
The men all fell in line behind
George Weah and then complained
that the women supporting
Ellen were sexist [laughter].
It was a remarkable display.
Given the choice between
a football player
with no credible college
education, but two fantastic goals
against Bayern and Verona, and a
Harvard educated development expert.
The top male presidential candidates
who fell short in the runoff
with one exception,
endorse the football player.
Weah meanwhile honing
his message for why he
and not the old lady
should run Liberia settled
on an educated people
have failed theme.
You know book, you not know
book, I will vote for you,
became the Weah runoff slogan.
And that theme was endorsed
by the failed male presidential
candidates who endorsed him.
Liberia had one of the lowest
literacy rates in the world.
So an illiterate population
would identify with a president
who dropped out of school, right?
Wrong. What the men who
endorsed that strategy failed
to realize is how much the very
idea was angering the market women.
Those women may not have
been educated themselves.
But they worked day and night in
the fields and the market stalls
to send their children to school.
Now the men were telling them
that education was not important.
Just as the men fell in behind Weah,
the women fell in behind Ellen.
It did not happen all at once.
Female political candidates had
appeared all over the ballot
in the elections running for senate
and the house on the same ticket
as Weah and Tubman and
the other male candidates.
But once the time came for
campaigning for the runoff,
those allegiances peeled
away, as even the women
who were staunch members of parties
that oppose Ellen's unity party
abandoned their men and took
up a new mantra -- vote for a woman.
Door to door the market women passed
out T-shirts and handed out flyers.
They slept on the side of the road
at night curled up on their mats.
They walked from village to village
exhorting women to vote for a woman.
We as supporters responded by
predicting that if she lost,
the country would go back to war.
No Weah, no peace -- they chanted.
Thus the runoff started
resembling past elections,
like the one in 1985, in which
Doe supporters had suggested the
same thing.
Vote for Doe or the
country goes back to war.
In Liberia this tactic was how
men managed to get their way.
They simply threatened the people.
Except that in November 2005, they
appeared to have met their match
because the women had
their own tricks.
Tricks that would make Weah's
tactics look like boys play.
You want beer?
Jack, give me your voter ID
card, I will buy you beer.
I say we buy voter
ID cards [inaudible].
Who looking for money?
Jack, bring your voter ID card.
The group of women had
stationed themselves
at a bar near the ELW8
junction, a major intersection
in Monrovia along the
road to Roberts Field.
The women set to work luring the
young men in a time honored fashion.
Except this time it was
not sex on the table.
This time the women were
the ones with the cash
and the young men were the ones
with the commodity for sale.
Some of those boys
were finish stupid,
one market woman recalled
with a smirk.
She was happy to go into detail
about what she called the
women's crafty techniques.
We were crafty she said,
one silver tooth glinting
in the sunshine as she laughed.
Many of the young men thought
that they were done with voting
after the first round
and did not understand
that they would need their ID cards
again if their man was actually
to assume the presidency.
Others knew and did not care.
Late in the evening of a muggy
hot day, the lure of a crispy cold
and multi-club beer far out shown
whatever benefits they thought their
voter ID cards could bring them.
As for the ones who were too
smart to sell their voter card,
well their mothers simply
stole them [laughter].
Some of the [inaudible] said
they would be voting [inaudible],
voting for George Weah, they
[inaudible] their ID cards,
Parley Harris said [assumed
spelling] said, looking sheepish
and defiant at the same time.
One market woman who agreed
to be referred to as the Oma,
said she snuck into her son's
room while he was sleeping.
Slipped his voter ID
card out of his wallet
and buried it in the
yard [laughter].
Years later there was
no shame among the women
who stole their son's ID cards.
Yeah I took it.
So what? The Oma said.
That foolish boy, what he knew?
I carried him for nine months.
I took care of him.
I fed him when he were hungry.
Then he would take the whole
country and give it away?
You would get elephant heads or
childhood [inaudible] [laughter].
[ Applause ]
After burying their
son's voter ID cards,
the women supporting Ellen then dug
up an old video of
a naked George Weah.
Somehow a 14-year-old commercial
for cologne that Weah made
in Italy just happened to
surface in the Liberian media.
In the commercial, Weah at the
time a world famous striker
with the football team A.C.
Milan, walks into a restaurant
to greet his white dinner date
after dousing himself in cologne.
He is fully clothed
at the beginning.
But when the woman sees him from
across the room, she is so overcome
that she imagines him naked.
The commercial then cuts to a naked
Weah strolling across the restaurant
to his date, while other white women
in the restaurant drool
and fan themselves.
Finally, Weah arrives at the table,
leans over it towards
his date and smiles.
When he sits down,
he is clothed again.
And he says suavely,
[foreign language].
To get an idea of how
this commercial played
in Liberia [laughter], you have
to understand this countries
bible spouting puritanism
and its deep racial scars.
Many of the freed American slaves
who founded Liberia were the mixed
race children of white slave owners,
who proceeded to setup the same kind
of society from which they had fled.
Except this time, the lighter skin
colonists were the upper class,
lording it up over
the native Liberians.
So matters of race still
struck deep into the heart
of the average Liberians.
That is why for many
Liberians it was bad enough
that Weah was strutting
around naked on Italian TV,
but in front of white women.
That was too much.
Weah walked butt naked
screamed the headline
in the New Democrat Newspaper, which
provided this hilarious synopsis
of the commercial for those
without access to YouTube.
The video seen portrays white women
in looks of sexual awe and ecstasy,
glancing at the black man
with his athletic build
and muscular features exposing
his genitals flipping walking
before them.
Weah's political supporters
tried to brazen their way out.
Mr. Weah committed no
crime by posing butt naked,
one party official [laughter]
helpfully told reporters.
Only constitutional deviants
should not be elected.
But the body politic quickly dusted
off their holier than thou clothes.
Adopting the convoluted
sentence structure,
at which Liberian men
were particularly adept.
Joshua Duncan Freedom, Principal of
the Kind Pentecostal High School,
told reporters if the
congress for democratic change
through its vocal [inaudible]
and justify George
Weah's butt naked video
on the international
information super highway
on some constitutional right, then
Liberia must be prepared God forbid
under a CDC rule to give audience
to the legality and normalness
of murder and even
cannibalism [laughter].
The truth is this cloak of religious
indigitation simply covered
up what Liberians of both
sexes were really mad about.
That Weah was flashing his
oiled, well chiseled body,
buttocks included in
front of white women.
Liberian women saw it as a
rejection of black women.
Liberian men were jealous.
Either way, this was a
loser issue for Weah,
as Ellen supporters
knew it would be.
On Tuesday, November 8th, the
people of Liberia woke up and went
to the polls for the
second time in four weeks.
There was a real and
palpable sense in the air
that something big was happening.
Helpful poll workers
at a polling station
in Sinkor were allowing pregnant
women and nursing mothers to cut
to the front of the line.
So Bernice Freeman, Louise Yussa
[assumed spelling] and a handful
of other women were passing around
babies and toddlers [laughter].
You want borrow the baby,
Bernice was grinning at one woman,
sneaking a furtive
look over her shoulder.
Put a baby on your back.
To another woman she had
advised, act pregnant.
If they think you are pregnant,
you can vote in the front.
It was unclear whether the poll
workers noticed how many different
women were carrying the
same baby [laughter].
The [foreign language].
That night a bunch of women were
listening to the election news
when an informant came
in with an update.
The official results
were not in yet.
Some polls were still open.
The final tally would
not be known for weeks.
But already there was a whisper in
the air from Ellen's spies posted
at different polling placed.
People were not supposed to disclose
voting trends at the polling booths
for fear of swaying those who
had not cast their vote, yet.
Yet. But all across the country,
Ellen's army of women were finding
ways to skirt the regulation.
For Lusoo Sloan [assumed spelling],
the work around came by reverting
to an old nursery school chant used
to teach children the alphabet.
S-O so. G-O go.
N-O no. Every Liberian
kid knows this chant.
For Lusoo on runoff night, the
chant took on a new meaning.
Hanging outside a polling booth,
she nervously asked an
informant how the vote was going.
He eyed the voting officials in
attendance, then grinned slightly.
S-O so. G-O go.
N-O no, he sang.
Then he added, U-P up.
Unity Party up.
Lusoo started dancing
and singing glee.
S-O so. G-O go.
N-O no. U-P up.
U-P up. When the election officials
glared at her, she sassed them.
You cannot stop me from
singing my S-O so, she said.
U-P up. She went to
bed that night singing.
The old lady was in the lead.
On Wednesday morning Ellen woke
up and walked into her living room
to find it already full
of campaign aides excited
about the preliminary returns
from Lofa and Nimba Counties.
She was not just in the lead.
She was in the lead by a lot.
60 percent to 40 percent.
It was a lead that she never
relinquished during the days
of counting that followed.
The old lady would
be Madame President.
Out of the 25 years of carnage
that was Liberia's decent
into hell had emerged a new leader.
And that person was a
67-year-old grandma.
On November 23rd after the
official results were announced,
Ellen was heading back to her house
from Campaign Headquarters
juggling congratulatory phone calls
from all over the world.
In the backseat of her
SUV, her American friend,
Steve Cashin, turned
to her grinning.
The White House just
called, he said.
President Bush wants to talk to you.
He recited a very secure
encrypted phone number.
Call that number.
A minute later Ellen
was on the phone
with the American President
accepting his congratulations.
Then the phone went dead.
Liberia in 2005 had no
landlines thanks to the war.
So everyone used cell phones.
They paid for that service
from Lonestar Cell Company
by purchasing scratch cards
from [inaudible] boys
on the side of the road.
The President Elect of Liberia
had just run out of credit
on her scratch card [laughter].
Turning to Cashin, Ellen smirked,
this is not very presidential
at all is it?
When word spread about
Ellen's victories,
the markets of Monrovia emptied
as the women who minded the stalls
at Rally Time and Nancy Door
[assumed spelling] and Red Light
and Painsfield [assumed spelling]
ran jubilant into the streets.
Go to school!
Some of them yelled.
Do not play football [laughter].
I still think about that
woman I saw in Bukavu
in the Congo all those
years ago, the one walking
with her husband carrying
all those logs on her back.
In so many ways, I guess
this book is for her.
Thank you.
And I am happy to answer
any questions.
[ Applause ]
>> Hi thank you for your
wonderful presentation.
I was expecting a lot.
I was not expecting nudity,
so that was great [laughter].
>> Helene Cooper: You need to really
Google the George Weah naked video.
>> I am afraid now.
>> Helene Cooper: Nah
you got to do it.
I have spent hundreds
of times in, you know,
research hours watching
it [laughter].
>> Research.
I like research a lot that way.
My question is actually.
There is a big part of
Johnson Sirleaf's story that is
to do with her education.
And I had the opportunity to
meet her about 10 years ago just
after she was elected, very briefly.
I am sure she does not
remember me, obviously.
And she talked a lot about
how she wanted to do a lot
around education for her country.
And then surprisingly though 10
years later progress has not been
as fast as expected.
And last she made a controversial
decision to bring in a public
for profit education company, Bridge
Academies, and just to like kind
of collective gasp of
education advocates and sort
of public education
advocates and I am wondering.
Because I understand that she
has a lot of competing priorities
and number she would
be committed to that.
Do you have any insight
about why maybe
in a broader spectrum what
she is up against in terms
of bringing education for
all to the kids of Liberia.
>> Helene Cooper: Education is
a huge deal and for the entirety
of her presidency, test scores
in Liberia stayed in the toilet.
A big part of that is
because of the Civil War.
You have to remember that for almost
two decades everything stopped.
Nobody went to school.
So you do not have, you
do not even have teachers
in Liberia today who are able.
It is not just a matter
of building schools.
You have to have people who
know how to read and write
in order to teach students.
And so it is such a
big, a big challenge.
It is a huge uphill battle.
I think her decision to bring in
Bridge was definitely controversial.
But it is not as if
the education system
in Liberia could get any worse
than it already has been.
It has been pretty, pretty bad.
So, I am very curious
to see how Bridge does.
I am sort of a skeptic myself.
But at this point people are
throwing a lot of different ideas
out there in an effort to get.
One thing that is a little bit
hopeful though is now I spent.
Whenever I go back to Liberia,
I do go into schools
and I talk to students.
And one thing I have noticed
is that the young girls
in the school systems in
Liberia now seem to all think
that they can be president,
which is actually,
it has been kind of
a cool thing to see.
>> Thank you.
>> Hello.
>> Helene Cooper: Hi.
>> I just wanted to say first of
all, I enjoyed your commentary
on Meet the Press when you are on.
So thank you so much for that.
>> Helene Cooper: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> My question has to
do with an ancestor.
My great grandfather had visited
Monrovia in about 1920-21.
And what I would like to know is
they did, someone did an interview
with him but we do
not have the masthead
to tell us where the source was.
Since the Civil War,
are there any records
or archival information available?
I do not know what the,
the structure sounds
like it you know is kind of tore up.
So, do you know if there is any,
the newspapers or any other source?
>> Helene Cooper: Yes and no.
There is a history
museum in Monrovia.
But they have got.
It was destroy.
It was very, not completely
destroyed,
but it was crippled during the
Civil War and a lot of stuff was,
a lot of artifacts were destroyed.
So there is something
that is still there.
There is a national
archives in Liberia.
So, you know, you can look there.
There is. Liberia has a very, very
healthy newspaper competition.
And there is a health press there.
So there are a lot of newspapers.
But I do not know if they
are going to have archives
that are going to go back to 1920.
So, it sort of.
You might have to go and kind of.
I mean, I think it
would help if you know,
if you knew who did the
interview and where.
Did it appear in a newspaper?
>> I believe it appeared
in a newspaper
because of the way it was written.
>> Helene Cooper: Yeah but they were
not doing microfiche and that kind
of stuff in Liberia back then.
So.
>> Okay. Well maybe I
will visit the country.
Thank you.
>> Hi. Thank you for your book.
>> Helene Cooper: Thank you.
>> I mean I have worked with
President Sirleaf for a while.
And I am continuing
on a project with her.
And your book was just.
I did not think anything could
get better than her autobiography.
But the way that you were
able to extract that,
merge it with your own interviews
and put your objective lens on it.
I mean it really is,
it is a tour de force.
>> Helene Cooper: Thank you.
>> For people who want to
read on women in politics.
My question to you is now
that President Sirleaf's
presidency is coming to an end
and you have had the Liberian
education trust with the, you know,
with the success that she has
had in education in that arena.
You have got the rebuilding
of the hospitals,
some of the roads are back.
You certainly have.
She has gotten.
She is indicted and bringing to
trial some of the major leaders
in the government for corruption.
And of course Ebola.
What do you think her most
long lasting legacy is?
>> Helene Cooper: I think
it has got to be the women.
It is. There is no way, no matter.
And she has had.
She has had sort of.
There is. She has a lot of flaws and
her 12 years have disappointed a lot
of people who expected more,
while at the same time she has still
been the best that we have had ever.
But I think that when you look at
the legacy that she leaves behind,
I cannot say enough how big
a deal that gender barrier
that she busted through is.
The idea that all over Liberia you
have women who have now carried,
who have for years
carried this country
on their backs economically
realizing that they can turn
that into political power.
And you do not have a viable female
candidate running to replace her.
But that does not matter
because I think
that in the future the women now
have understand these market women
now understand just how powerful
they can be when they want to.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Helene Cooper: Thank you.
>> Hi. I was an education volunteer
in Liberia I think around the time
when your first book came out
and before, in preparation
for my trip I tried to find and read
as much as possible about Liberia
and most of the books were
out of print at that time.
I ended up going to Liberia, loving
my experience and lived there
for three years and now
I am actually getting PhD
and my topic is around Liberia.
And my question to you is I
want to know if you could talk
about where you see or what your
intent is in terms of historiography
on Liberia and a lot of the material
that is out there is inaccurate
or just there are lots
of gaps in that as well.
So I am wondering if you could speak
to history on Liberia and literature
that may be coming out
or what you see there.
>> Helene Cooper: Well
you are right.
There is not a lot out there.
I realized that when I was
working on my first book.
But there is more than people think.
And there is a growing cadre
of Liberian writers,
who are also putting.
And some of them are here now.
Who are putting their
own stories to paper.
So I think you are going to see, you
are going to see more coming out.
But you are absolutely right.
There is a lot of things were
destroyed during the war.
This is a culture.
Liberia is a culture
that has much more
of an oral tradition
than a written one.
And the writing is starting,
is you know picking up now.
But no we do not have a lot of.
There are history books on Liberia.
But you are again right that
not all of them are accurate.
>> Yes, I too wanted to thank
you for Madame President.
I just finished reading it.
I am a return Peace Corp volunteer
and I actually taught history
and English at Senacaly [assumed
spelling] Central High School.
And there was.
And this was in the 60's.
And there was only one
woman in my classes.
There were not all that men either
because the high school was
fairly new and you know.
So the students were
like in their 30's
who were graduating
from high school.
But there was only that one
woman and I always felt for her.
But, I wondered.
It is my understanding there
was another election that is
around the corner in Liberia and
there are a bunch of candidates.
I believe Weah is running again.
>> Helene Cooper: He could win.
>> That is what I was
going to ask you.
What is your perspective
on that election?
>> Helene Cooper: It is going
to be a great election to cover.
As a reporter I am like drooling
because you have all
these characters running.
Not just Weah, who.
But Charles Taylor's
wife is running.
His former allies are running.
We have got George Weah's
baby momma was running,
but she just pulled out.
[Laughter].
It is such a. It is
like it is such a great.
I mean, Liberia is, as a reporter it
is like shooting fish in a barrel.
You just go there and
the stories just pile up.
I think it is going
to be interesting.
You have this Pepsi Cola heir,
former board of directors,
executive of Pepsi, Alex Cummings.
And there is the Vice President,
who is sort of viewed as kind
of the establishment candidates.
But it is.
You know, Liberia.
Liberians can be very perverse.
And I do not at this point know who
they are going to end up going with.
I do not think anybody
can call it right now.
It is completely a free for all.
I cannot wait to go
home to cover it.
>> Are the women coalescing behind
any candidate for this election?
>> Helene Cooper: No.
And in. Back in 2005 they had not,
at this point in the election
cycle they had not coalesced behind
Ellen either.
>> Thank you.
>> Helene Cooper: Thank you.
Yes sir?
>> Helene first I want to thank
you for writing this book.
It is. It is very impressive
that like women's history
is coming to the limelight.
My question is in 38 days from now
we are going to have an election
in the Liberia, specifically
on October 10th or October 8th.
It is most likely that this
naked soccer player is going
to be the next president.
What are your thoughts about,
what is this going to mean
for the future of Liberia?
The economy is a mess.
Healthcare is a mess.
Education is a mess.
And the citizens are
hungry for, you know,
much more because they you know,
they have been disappointed a bit.
A lot of the things that
have improved in Liberia,
as far as the security, as far
as other parts of the economy.
But you know going forward, what
do you think this is going to mean
as far as this, what are these
people, either his baby momma
or someone else becoming president.
And also what do you think Ellen
is going to do going forward
to remain part of Liberia's
fabric, political fabric,
as well as societal fabric.
Thank you.
>> Helene Cooper: Thank you.
First of all, so I would not assume.
I do not think it is
a foregone conclusion
that George Weah is going to win.
I think it is, as I said earlier
I think it is a free for all.
I think anybody at
this point could win.
And I think that, you know,
maybe people grow into roles.
I do think that one of the
reasons I find, one of the places
where I find optimism
is that in the 12 years
that Ellen Johnson Sirleaf has been
president, she has really opened
up freedom of speech and freedom
of the press in Liberia to levels
that we have never had before.
So the Liberian people are far
less tolerant of the sort of things
that they accepted decades ago.
That is one of the reasons why
with Ebola, Liberia was hit harder
than either Sierra Leone or Guinea.
But Liberia came out of
it much faster than either
of those other two countries.
And I think that is in large part
because Liberian people were
not going to tolerate you know,
the kind of inaptitude that would
cause this to linger and linger.
So, I think that the sort of free
for all atmosphere that we have
in Liberia and the freedom
of speech and the freedom
to criticize is something
that Liberians are not going
to be willing to let go of.
And I think that is
something that causes me
to feel a little bit more
optimistic about our future.
I am being shown a rap it up sign.
So, I think this is all the
time that we have today.
I really appreciate all of you
coming in on this rainy Saturday.
Thank you very much.
[Applause].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.